liberal cities losing control during the
rampant crime wave stunning stats
obtained by the new york post show the
same 10 career offenders racked up
nearly 500 arrests since new york's bail
reform laws went into effect in 2020
mayor eric adams says liberals making
the laws have lost their minds
they say the difference
definition of insanity is to do the same
thing repeatedly but expect different
results
our criminal justice system is insane
it is dangerous it is harmful and it's
destroying the fabric of our city
meanwhile liberal manhattan d.a alvin
bragg is pushing back saying he's proud
of what the city is doing and the 80
year old california liquor store owner
who was forced to defend himself when an
armed robber barged into his stores
calling out leaders for making things
unsafe check out what he told jesse
it's not my job to get them into gear
somebody needs to do something now
because we're just getting downhill
faster and faster and
it's certainly a concern not just to me
but i hear it all the time from my
customer base
and
everybody that i'm exposed to
is really fed up
and i certainly can't blame
and jesse thank god that he recovered
from his heart attack that he suffered
after
that attempted robbery and he was at
work the next day he needs better hair
than you he has great hair
so
here's what's happening in new york uh
we we used to have remember we used to
have a democrat a republican mayor
we used to have a republican senator
governor we had checks against democrat
craziness and now there's no check so
this is what happens when democrats
control the entire state usually wall
street would step in when things got
crazy and say hey guys relax try to act
normal
after covid all the power brokers that
used to run these banks on wall street
they just left they went to connecticut
they went to florida they went to the
hamptons so they're not living or
working in the city anymore so they have
no personal investment in new york city
that's why they're not
you know greasing the governor that's
why they're not spending money on
lobbyists because you it doesn't take a
lot of money to like knock these bail
reform laws down these legislatures in
the albany make like a hundred grand a
year you give them a couple dollars
they'll do whatever you want no one's
doing that though all right they've
totally checked out also race after the
george floyd riots
everyone got really scared of being
labeled a racist remember you know black
lives matter everyone put like the black
thing on their instagram they were even
getting pillaged and robbed and they
were like yes black lives matter we
totally support these riots and because
they didn't want to be called racist so
if some guy with deep pockets wall
street went and tried to lobby this
stupid governor uh hochel who i hate
saying the name hope i hate saying that
to reverse this bail thing
they would be smeared as racist and they
don't want that brand uh hit and that's
why they're just laying low and letting
this whole city decay that's right vocal
will be gone soon so don't worry you
don't have to say it anymore harold
when jesse mentions checks on the system
arguably the different positions within
the system act as checks themselves and
you would think the prosecutor the
district attorney would be that who
represents the state the state's
interest in prosecuting crimes but
they're in florida governor desantis
took action when his state d.a andrew
warren refused to prosecute laws he
removed him today for incompetence and
willful defiance of his duties he said
look there's a difference between
prosecutorial discretion which is
individualized in case by case and
someone just flat out abdicating their
duty do you think we're going to see
more of this across the country as
people wake up to the fact that these
da's are not doing their jobs i don't
know all the details there in florida
but governor desantis seemed like he was
in the right to do that he had the
authority to do it and governors who
have that authority should exercise it
when it's going to advance
public safety look we sometimes the only
difference i have about we we sometimes
talk about democrats and liberals look
even bakersfield california where kevin
mccarthy represents they have two times
the murder rate there and they do in los
angeles tulsa jacksonville mobile
alabama all have republican mayors but
we shouldn't talk about it that way the
way you're talking about emily i agree
with in a way jesse's
i think the thrust of what jesse says i
agree with wholeheartedly i'm not
convinced that it's because the the the
business people leaders of these banks
have moved out what i think it is is
voters have to go to the polls and vote
for people who are going to stand up to
criminals the mayor of this town who's
black who's a democrat uh has been his
outs has been as outspoken opinionated
and firm on this issue of saying we want
police officers on the street we want to
support our police officers and we have
to reform these bail laws democrats if
we just do one thing
reform the bail laws the front of the
new york post here today
talking about those few criminals who've
committed all these crimes because
they've not been kept behind bars i get
why we wanted to reform the bail laws
from the beginning ensuring that we
didn't put people in jail who had just a
mental health issue ensuring that we
didn't put people in jail who had small
amounts of things but we have a problem
we're letting people out of jail who are
committing violent acts no american
black white hispanic democrat or
republican wants this so i hope we stop
talking about
blue and red and start talking about how
we ensure that we get good prosecutors
we police that we staff the police like
they should be staffed and politicians
who don't want to do that they'll get a
rude awakening at the poll but greg the
irony is the first identity for example
of that disgraced uh state attorney in
florida the first identity on his
twitter was criminal justice reformer so
these guys are hiding behind
that cloak and yet totally failing at
their duty because they're not making
that distinction between violence and
not violence there's no common sense
whatsoever well and also i mean i agree
with harold that people need to go and
vote but the problem is this is a
one-party town so we don't have that you
got to have blue and red because red
will help the blue and blue will help
the red but if you just have a one-party
rule there are no breaks to slow the the
truck down as it's heading towards a
cliff so you get all these really
radical reformers and you get these
boudins and these gas cones and there's
nobody there to stop them
why do they continue robbing and after
they keep getting arrested i realized
for these thieves this guy these thieves
averaged like 50 to 70 arrests
it's like they're it's like they're
business travelers and that's their tsa
it's like it's a hassle i got to go
through this you know i'm going to go
out rob today i gotta go okay get the
cop comes again yeah you took out you
got me and you started emptying your
stuff out yeah you got this you got this
and you and then the cop says you can go
now and then you go on and you do more
that's what it is it just comes with the
deal i think you know i go i go to the
that advice that i i mentioned i think
it was last week and i still believe
fund halfway houses on the blocks where
the da's like alvin bragg live create
facilities out of old facilities for
house arrest and put them in governor
hopkins neighborhood the you know the
way the nyc has become a sanctuary city
for repeat offenders so they need to do
what the border states did to dc which
is put it on their doorstep like a
flaming bag of poop and i think you can
do that i mean you but first you got to
get rid of the governor and i hope
you're right but i don't know man but
there's a lot of democrats in this state
i'm lighting candles and hope and dagon
in that report it included
liberals on the left saying oh no no
this is cherry-picking statistics
because bail reform is working how can
you argue with the statistics of three
times the amount of rest since arrests
since 2016 this was implemented police
ambushes up 300 plus percent those
statistics do not lie i woke up a week
ago to a gunfight
in my neighborhood
where the police were well two robbery
suspects were firing on police and they
exchanged gunfire later that day there
was a psychotic violent man
who attacked um went after a bouncer
when i was having some beers
and the bouncer knocked him out cold and
all the patrons having beers and fries
just sat there and watched him lay
bleeding in the street nobody was going
to go near him because he's a psychotic
dangerous criminal
cops eventually showed up but that was
in one day i've lived here 30 years i've
never seen anything like that
and
this just in new york i was talking to
somebody who worked in the district
attorney's office under morgenthau he
was um when dinkins was mayor and he
said
it basically said everything in the
system right now is stacked in favor of
the criminal and even if you reform the
bail laws where
you have criminals who will get held on
bail rather than you know you get caught
with uh you're a
suspected murderer you're right back out
on the street
even if you reform the bail laws
in new york city
the criminal judges that are kind that
are are appointed up to 10-year terms by
the mayor
so we have eight years of bill de blasio
and we have an entire stable
of criminal court judges and they are
the
uh they make the kind of most day-to-day
bail decisions
so you have as this gentleman pointed
out eight years of de blasio criminal
court judges
hacked judges a change in the bail law
won't
improve the quality of the judges and
elected district attorneys who will not
make arrests all these assistant da's
adas are leaving because there's nobody
to prosecute
they're not arresting people
again a liberal layer cake of horribles
it is vile you know and i know we have
to go but these
asses who run these large corporations
they need to get the hell out of new
york no more fundraisers no more
campaign contributions no more cocktail
parties take your jobs elsewhere then
these liberals will stand up but again
like daniel enriquez
he was murdered on a subway train worked
for goldman sachs where in the hell is
goldman sachs on this
money only talks when money walks i will
say it again
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else